Let's pray together over day 31. Holiness is
beholding God's glory.
Father, we thank you for the glory that you have displayed to
us. You are incredibly, beautifully,
wonderfully glorious, and we praise you for
the beautiful outshining of your unique holy
excellence. We praise you that it is jaw-dropping,
earth-shattering, and soul-satisfying.
We thank you, Lord, for the assurance that your glory is
why you do what you do, and we behold that glory.
We look to you today because the glories of Earth
are fading and not lasting, and they are not
satisfying. And so we turn our eyes to you, and we fix our
eyes on Jesus, on the ministry of Jesus and the
work of Jesus and the person of Jesus and the excellence of Jesus.
We turn our back on the old way of a fading glory and
a hiding from God and a bondage and a despair.
And we turn our back on the old covenant that
revealed holiness and could command holiness but could not
empower holiness. Oh, thank you, Lord, for the new covenant and
the power of Jesus through his blood and through the Holy Spirit that he's
given. He has opened the door for
us, and we look to his face. We look to his face
and his character and his beauty and his finished work for us,
and we fix our eyes on him. And we ask, oh Lord, that
the glow of the glory of Jesus would soak down
into us and that we would be transformed.
Oh God, to be like what we see when we
look at Jesus. Oh, to be like him, as pure
as he is. So we pray, oh Lord, that you'd come in your
fullness and in your sweetness and you'd stamp your own image
deep on our heart as we behold your glory with an unveiled face.
Thank you, Jesus.
We encourage you to continue to pray and ask the Lord to do these things and
accomplish these things in your heart.